So this topic probably doesn’t sound very
interesting, but I promise it’s at least
somewhat interesting.
Keep in mind that everything I’m saying
here is about the most efficient and profitable
design of a grocery store so don’t go complaining
if your neighborhood Tesco or Safeway isn’t
exactly the same, but chances are next time
you go to the grocery store you’ll notice
at least some of these principles at work.
Let’s start with the entrance of the grocery
store.
Americans in particular love shopping in a
counter-clockwise path.
For this reason, the door to grocery stores
will typically be on the right hand side in
the United States and the checkout counters
will be on the left.
In the UK, it’s often the opposite.
For this reason, researchers speculate that
this tendency to move in one direction is
linked to the side of the road that the two
demographics drive on.
In one research study, Americans’ desire
to move in a counter-clockwise path in a grocery
store was so great that they actually went
around physical barriers that researchers
put up in the store in order to move in a
counterclockwise direction.
This tendency actually works in stores’
favor as well.
Research shows that profits are higher in
US grocery stores with an entrance to the
right.
It allows individuals to be move in the path
that they like and also exposes shoppers to
the most amount of merchandise possible.
In fact, Americans spend on average $2 more
per trip when they move through a grocery
store in a counter-clockwise pattern.
This may not seem like much, but when considering
that every American goes to the grocery store
an average of 1.5 times per week, or 78 times
a year, this amounts to enormous differences
in profits.
The periphery of grocery store is also very
calculated.
Items that are almost always purchased in
a trip to the grocery store—milk, meat,
eggs—are spread out around the perimeter
to force the shopper to be exposed to the
most merchandise possible.
Shoppers will almost always need to go to
these sections, so the position of the milk,
meat, and eggs dictates the way a shopper
can move through the store.
Within the center isles, some retailers will
put the most sold items in the center of the
isles to force the shopper to walk by even
more merchandise.
Looking at the cereal section, we can see
the principle of “eye level is buy level”.
In the ideal circumstance, the most profitable
cereals are put at eye level.
This often means that large brand name cereals
are put in these middle shelves.
At a kid’s eye level, retailers will often
put the sugary kind of cereal that kids will
pester their parents for.
Often on the bottom levels are the bulk price
or generic brand cereals.
Those who are being frivolous are usually
willing to look around for the best deals
and often have clear intent to buy the product
ahead of time.
It’s much more likely that individuals will
impulsively buy brand name cereal than bulk
size generic cereal.
On the top level is usually the healthy or
small-brand cereal.
Usually those who are buying healthy cereal
have clear intent to buy that cereal, and
profits are often lower on these cereals.
Also a prime location for items that retailers
want to push is the endcaps—the ends of
isles.
Almost all shoppers will pass these endcaps
because of the perimeter pattern we discussed
earlier.
Interestingly, the liquor store monopoly in
Sweden uses this principle in reverse.
The monopoly was created by the government
to promote moderation in alcohol consumption
so one of the things they do to prevent impulse
purchases is not have any endcap displays.
So thats all the ways the layout of grocery
stores is designed to manipulate you.
Next time you go to the grocery store look
out for some of these retail principles and
I’m sure you’ll be able to spot at least
some of them.